I'm down to do it as many times as  people want to see here really I mean  I'm gonna get this one out first  yeah like I mean  I've talked to Matt about the idea of  doing a Trilogy and uh and that would be  wonderful I mean I really really enjoyed  the process and it's such a fun  character to play and yeah it'll be  that'd be lovely lovely there's so much  room for this Batman to grow too yes  really big time I think this is what it  is  Bruce Wayne in this big time  there's a giant party boy no I I'm  really that is something I think but I  think because you're such a recluse  Bruce is such a recluse in this film to  see Bruce evolve into the person that  knows he has to perform and be on a  yacht with some like that's a really fun  journey to to go on I really don't know  it's like you need to be Batman again  I'm out of all I'm at Fashion  [Laughter]